surviving in a big family can be
challenging Lincoln we know you've got
it rough with so many sisters to deal
with but lighten up as it turns out you
could have had way more sisters than the
ones you currently have not to mention
the fact that you and your family were
almost bunnies instead of human kids
what so the next time Lucy blows up the
house just remember to be thankful
you're not living with a bunch of crazy
rabbits
some scenes were just too outlandish
even for Nickelodeon floud house we
found some scenes that were totally
banned in other countries we also got
the scoop on some deleted sisters and
some scenes that never made it to
television here are 10 loud house scenes
that were banned or deleted watch until
the end to find out which angry sister
was removed from the show big family
could be challenging but it's not
impossible
beverly did you guys know that the
characters in the loud house were
originally supposed to be bunny rabbits
okay now the enormous amount of siblings
makes sense
unfortunately not all the sisters made
the cup when they switched over to human
territory in the episode titled white
hair we see what the loud family would
have looked like as rabbits and we see a
few sisters we haven't seen before like
Beverly she's kind of a cross between
Lori and Luanne but since we already
have Lori and Luanne there was no need
for Beverly in turn for the worse in the
episode titled in turn for the worse
Lincoln and Clyde are super excited to
work at flips food and fuel there's a
funny scene where the microwave is
broken so Lincoln decides to heat a
burrito in front of the exhaust pipe of
mrs. Jelinski scars this is the scene
that was banned in the UK they thought
it sent the wrong message to kids
Brooke meet Brooke she's another bunny
sister who didn't cross over into the
human loud family
we only know her as the paranoid
neurotic bunny sister named Brooke this
little bunny is stressed out to the max
in her only episode of the show maybe
Brooke just couldn't handle the anxiety
of more than one episode that's a lot of
stress for one little bunny drink prank
this deleted scene is pretty popular
among the loud house band
it's so funny fans wish it made the
final cut it's the scene in April Fool's
rules where Louie Ann pulls a pretty
funny prank on Lincoln he wakes up to go
to the bathroom only to find out that
Luanne has filled every inch of his
bedroom floor with cups of water he has
to drink his way through all the cups in
the bathroom and hallway to get to the
bathroom by the time he gets to the
bathroom door he's doing the potty dance
from all the water Lou Ann laughs
hysterically when the doorknob comes off
in Lincoln's hand no one knows for sure
why the scene was deleted maybe it was
cut due to time constraints overnight
success the loud house has had entire
episodes of the show banned from other
countries for violating their laws one
episode in particular was banned in
Russia the episode was overnight success
it's the one where Clyde goes over to
Lincoln's house for his sleepover
hi mr. MacBride hi mr. MacBride hi
Lincoln ready for your big night this
episode was banned in Russia for showing
Clyde's dad
Russia has a very strict anti LGBTQ law
that prohibits television episodes from
promoting love in all shapes and sizes
so it got the ax
winner takes all this is another deleted
scene that fans everywhere are talking
about it's from the episode winner takes
all in this episode Lynne is obsessed
with winning
she even compete over who is the best at
brushing their teeth the scene that
aired showed Lynne brushing her teeth so
hard that a tooth fell out but
originally they were going to have her
gums bleed like a lot they probably cut
this because it's super disturbing
Blanche meet Blanche another bunny
sister from the white hair episode her
allergies first Blanche is the sister
who was always sick with various
ailments and allergies but allergies and
illnesses are no laughing matter
Blanche could have been an interesting
character on the show if they focus more
on some interesting personality traits
and not only her chronic health problems
Fifa cheerio mates this sister embodies
every stereotype you can think of when
it comes to British folk
she's got a cheeky accent a little Derby
hat and of course an umbrella it's like
she read the cliff notes from Mary
Poppins and decided to play dress-up
Pippa doesn't fit in the loud house
family because she's more of a
caricature than a character April Fool's
Clyde there are so many pranks in the
episode titled April Fool's rules they
just couldn't fit them all in here's one
that didn't make the cut
in this scene Clyde trips a wire that
activates the sprinkler spraying him in
the face then the sprinklers turn on a
leaf blower blowing hey all over him the
hay sticks to his wet body and makes him
tasty bait for a bevy of nearby crows
alas this scene never made it into the
episode Brenda we've got one final
deleted sister for you
she's the character with the most
attitude we're talking about the
hot-headed bunny Brenda youtuber Calabi
productions pointed out that Brenda's
red dress is a strong indicator that
she's got a bad temper he referred to
the colour of anger and Disney's inside
out but there's a lot of anger to go
around among the loud siblings so they
ultimately decided to get rid of this
sister before you go tell us who your
favorite loud house character is in the
comments thanks for watching the things
hit that subscribe button to catch our
latest videos and while you're at it
give this video a big thumbs up see you
next time
[Music]